لكن اوكرانيا تشكك بنيه روسيا بعد اعلانها
سحب قواتها من خرسون الواقعه جنوب
اوكرانيا فكيف تتوقع استمرار القتال
للسيطره على المدينه الاستراتيجيه التي
اعلنت روسيا ضمها ضمن اراضيها الوطنيه
مؤخرا قرار الانسحاب جاء بعد ان امر وزير
الدفاع الروسي سرجي شايقو بالمضيق قدما في
سحب القوات خلال اجتماع مع عقائد العمليات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا معربا بانه امر ليس
سهلا على الاطلاق
مراقبون يقولون ان انسحاب موسكو يعد
انتكاسه جديده لكريم وخصوصا بعد ان انسحبت
من خارجيه الواقع شمال شرق اوكرانيا في
سبتمبر تحليلات غربيه تفيد بان الكريم ان
يحاول تاجيل هذا الانسحاب لاطول فتره
ممكنه حيث اصبح الوضع اصعب للقوات الروسيه
في مواجهه الجيش الاوكراني المجهز باسلحه
حديثه قدمها الحلفاء الغربي
[موسيقى]